- We are back with Billy Ray
Cyrus, Firerose and Sam J.
Give it up everybody.
(crowd cheering)
So last season we announced
that our partner Pilot Pen
was searching for their next $100,000
G2 Overachievers grant winner.
That is not a typo.
That is a hundred grand y'all.
There are some people out
there who go above and beyond
to make our world a better place.
Just walking around
here, just being angels.
And that certainly
describes my next guest.
Her organization helps
children in foster care
find forever families.
That's why Pilot selected her
as a G2 Overachievers finalist
and shared her story with us,
which we are so excited about.
Please everybody welcome Marcy Bursac,
along with Pilot's Vice
President of Marketing,
Ariann Langsam.
(audience cheering)
So meet everybody.
Hello!
And Marcy, I'm gonna start with you.
So explain to everybody,
forgotten adoption option.
- [Marcy] Kind of rolls
off the tongue, right?
- It really does.
It's very nice.
Yeah, explain how it works.
- Yeah so essentially I coach families
through the adoption process.
So many people are really familiar with
you can spend thousands of
dollars, tens of thousands,
to adopt a child and it
takes a long process.
Or you can become a foster parent
and maybe you'll adopt
that child, but maybe not.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- People often don't know
there's a third option,
and that's why it's called
the forgotten adoption option.
There are 30% of the children
currently in foster care
are adoptable right now
and you can adopt them.
And in fact, that process is shorter.
The financial investment
is at maximum $2,500.
The state often covers health insurance
for these children until they're 18.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, that's really the organization.
- And they're forgotten sometimes,
they're overlooked, right?
- [Marcy] They're overlooked, yes.
- Because I had never
heard of this before you.
- [Marcy] Now you have.
- Had you heard of this before?
I'd never heard of it.
Yeah, so what stood out about-
so many great organizations come across,
you know, your desk.
So what stood out about Marcy's?
- Well, what really stood out about Marcy
is that she is an incredible overachiever.
She fits with the G2 paradigm that
write more, do more, achieve more.
And I'm not sure if you know this,
but Marcy is a professional,
she's a technical analyst.
She also recently finished her MBA.
She has been a pageant
contestant and winner.
She's written.
- (snaps) Okay.
- Yeah, I know.
(Marcy laughing)
- Just all those little bullet points.
- But there's more.
Okay, so lemme keep going.
So she has written two books.
A third one is coming out very soon.
She is a podcaster, she is a wife,
she and her husband adopted
two children from foster care,
and in her spare time, Marcy has helped
over 12,000 families through the process.
(audience cheering)
- How do you have spare
time in all of that?
I'm like, what?
Where is the spare time?
- If I write a fourth book, it
might be on time management.
- I know.
I was like, yeah, I need
that book desperately.
(Ariann laughing)
So this work is very
personal to you, right?
- [Marcy] It is.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Kelly, when I
was in my early twenties
I had the opportunity to
go on a service project
over to an orphanage in Europe.
And I spent a good portion
of my week with teen girls.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Who were in this orphanage.
And it really hurt.
Like, I just felt the
burden in my heart of,
man, these kids, they're
growing up without a family.
And they're not just growing
up in their childhood.
They're growing up with their
lifetime without a family.
And when I came back to the US I thought,
I'm not okay with what I saw
and I need to do something about it.
And so I decided, I'm going
to adopt as my plan A.
And that's what my husband and I did.
We actually adopted two kids together.
They're biological siblings.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh, that's great!
(audience cheering)
Because it's good to keep
the siblings together.
- [Marcy] It is.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Marcy] Yeah, there's significant need.
There are a lot of
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- siblings, whether it's
two or more kids together,
that's a big need in
the foster care space.
And so I started blogging
about our experience
through what kind of is a
complicated, difficult process.
And that's what led to the organization
that I founded today.
- It's a very beautiful thing.
Well Ariann, you have
something to tell Marcy, right?
- Yes.
So Marcy we fully support what
you're doing and your mission
and you really have made
the impossible possible
for so many children.
And you know, just like the G2 pen,
longest writing, unstoppable-
you are unstoppable.
So we wanna offer you all the G2 pens
and writing instruments
that you need for yourself
and all the families
that you are working with
through the adoption process.
- Incredible.
(audience cheering)
- Well, actually there is one more thing
I wanted to tell you.
And that is, you are not just a finalist
for the G2 Overachievers grant.
You are in fact, the G2
Overachievers grant winner.
(audience cheering)
- Woo! That's one
hundred thousand dollars.
(audience cheering)
That's so cool.
Ah, well, here's some good news.
Marcy is today's a hundred thousand dollar
G2 Overachievers grant
winner but you can be next.
Pilot pen is once again
looking for adults and students
to go above and beyond
to make their communities
and the whole world better for us all.
That is why Pilot's hosting
the hundred thousand dollar
G2 Overachievers grant
and the $15,000 G2
Overachievers student grant.
They both go to outstanding overachievers
who go all out to improve
the lives of others.
Submissions for the 2023
G2 Overachievers grants
are open right now.
So don't wait too long y'all.
All submissions are due by December 15th.
Find out how to apply
at g2overachievers.com.
Stay right here, everybody
I'll tell you what I'm liking next.